I WON'T SAY GOOD MORNING TO YOU
BECAUSE IT'S NOT A GOOD MORNING
TO YOU.
HOW ARE YOU HOLDING UP?
>> I'M TAKING IT MINUTE BY
MINUTE, HOUR BY HOUR.
THIS TYPE OF SITUATION TENDS TO
COME IN WAVES, I FOUND, WITH
MYSELF AND OTHER PEOPLE THAT I
TALKED TO FROM THAT NIGHT.
>> CHAOTIC, CAN YOU TAKE US
INSIDE IF YOU DON'T MIND
RELIVING THIS?
>> OF COURSE.
OF COURSE.
IT -- I WAS WORKING BEHIND THE
BAR ON A SEEMINGLY NORMAL
SATURDAY NIGHT.
AND AROUND 11:55 OR SO, I HEARD
A FEW POPS.
POPPING SOUNDS.
AND AT FIRST I THOUGHT IT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE CADILACKIN
FANS THAT YOU SEE OFTEN AT LGBTQ
CLUBS.
WHEN I LOOKED UP, I REALIZED
THAT WAS NOT THE CASE.
I SAW THE OUTLINE OF A MAN
HOLDING A RIFLE AT THE ENTRANCE
OF THE CLUB JUST PROBABLY ABOUT
15 FEET FROM ME.
AND THEN, YOU KNOW, TOOK A
MOMENT TO REGISTER WHAT WAS
HAPPENING, BUT ONCE IT HIT ME
THIS WAS ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN
REAL LIFE TO ME AND MY FRIENDS,
I DUCKED BEHIND THE BAR.
AS I DID THAT, GLASS BEGAN TO
SPEW EVERYWHERE, ALL AROUND ME.
>> NOW I UNDERSTAND YOU KNEW
DANIEL ASTON, WHO WAS KILLED IN
THE CLUB?
>> YES.
>> CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> I'VE KNOWN DANIEL ASTON FOR A
FEW YEARS NOW.
MOST RECENTLY -- HE'S ALWAYS
BEEN A FRIEND TO ME, BUT HE WAS
MY SUPERVISOR AT CLUB Q.
HE WAS THE BAR SUPERVISOR AND HE
WAS THE BEST SUPERVISOR ANYBODY
COULD HAVE ASKED FOR.
HE MADE ME WANT TO COME INTO
WORK AND HE MADE ME WANT TO, YOU
KNOW, JUST BE A PART OF THE
POSITIVE CULTURE WE WERE TRYING
TO CREATE THERE.
AND HE WAS AN AMAZING PERSON.
HE WAS A LIGHT IN MY LIFE.
IT'S STILL SURREAL THAT WE'RE
EVEN TALKING ABOUT HIM IN THE
PAST TENSE LIKE THIS.
>> MY COLLEAGUES ARE HERE AS
WELL.
WE ALL HAVE SO MANY QUESTIONS
FOR YOU.
WE'RE SORRY -- I DIDN'T SAY
THAT.
WE'RE SORRY ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
>> THANK YOU, DON.
>> WE'RE SO SORRY.
LIKE DON SAID, IT'S TOUGH TO ASK
YOU ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED AND HAVE
YOU RELIVE IT, BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT AS YOU KNOW TO THE
INVESTIGATION, TO WHAT
INVESTIGATORS ARE LOOKING AT.
DID YOU HEAR THE SUSPECT SAY
ANYTHING?
I KNOW THERE WAS MUSIC PLAYING
BUT IT WAS LOUD BUT ALSO QUIET
BECAUSE PEOPLE OBVIOUSLY WERE
WITNESSING THIS SHOOTING, HIDING
FROM THIS PERSON.
DID YOU HEAR HIM SAY ANYTHING AS
THIS WAS GOING ON?
>> I -- THE CLOSEST I WAS TO HIM
WHERE I COULD PHYSICALLY SEE A
FULL BODY OF A PERSON WAS WHEN
HE IMMEDIATELY CAME INTO THE
CLUB.
I WAS NEVER CLOSE ENOUGH OR IT
WAS NEVER QUIET ENOUGH FOR ME TO
HEAR IF HE WAS SAYING ANYTHING
AT ALL.
YOU KNOW, I TRIED TO BE ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE TRYING TO
HIDE FROM HIM.
SO I -- I TRIED TO AVOID SEEING
HIM.
SO I DIDN'T HEAR ANYTHING, NO.
>> MICHAEL, THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US.
I KNOW THAT AT ONE POINT AS YOU
WERE HIDING YOU THOUGHT AS YOU
LOOKED AT THAT GUN, LOOKED RIGHT
AT THE BARREL OF THE GUN,
THOUGHT YOU WERE NOT GOING TO
MAKE IT AND YOU DID.
AND THERE WERE HEROES AROUND
YOU, RIGHT, WHO TOOK DOWN THE
GUNMAN.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT?
>> YES.
THERE WAS A MOMENT IN TIME WHERE
I FEARED I WAS NOT GOING TO MAKE
IT OUT OF THAT CLUB ALIVE.
AND I -- I HAD NEVER PRAYED SO
SINCERELY AND QUICKLY IN MY LIFE
AS I DID IN THAT MOMENT.
AS I WAS ANTICIPATING THAT
OUTCOME AND AFRAID FOR THAT
OUTCOME.
IT GOT QUIET AS I WAS PRAYING
AND HOPING, IT GOT SILENT, THE
GUN SHOTS STOPPED.
SO WE -- I STAYED THERE FOR A
MINUTE, MINUTE AND A HALF, YOU
KNOW, I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
I COULDN'T SEE, I WAS HIDDEN
DOWN IN THE CORNER.
SO I KEPT MY HEAD DOWN BUT AFTER
ABOUT A MINUTE AND A HALF I
DECIDED I NEEDED TO GET OUT OF
THERE.
SO I GOT UP AND WHEN I WENT
INSIDE, I SAW WHAT I BELIEVE WAS
PROBABLY THE GUNMAN LYING ON THE
GROUND GETTING BEAT UP AND
KICKED AND YELLED AT BY TWO VERY
BRAVE PEOPLE WHO I STILL DON'T
KNOW THE IDENTITY OF THOSE TWO
PEOPLE, BUT I HOPE I CAN FIND
OUT ONE DAY, BECAUSE I TRULY
BELIEVE THOSE TWO PEOPLE SAVED
MY LIFE.
>> OUR CORRESPONDENT NICK WATT,
POPPY SPOKE TO HIM MOMENTS
BEFORE YOU CAME ON.
HE SAYS -- I DON'T WANT TO GET
AHEAD OF MYSELF.
BUT HE SAID MOST PEOPLE THERE
HAVE MADE UP THEIR MINDS.
THEY BELIEVE IT WAS A HATE CRIME
THAT WAS PERPETRATED AGAINST THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING ABOUT THAT?
>> I -- I HAVE TO AGREE THAT --
I MEAN, THERE ARE SO MANY
CLUBS -- YOU LOOK AT HOW MANY
CLUBS ARE IN COLORADO SPRINGS
AND HOW MANY GAY CLUBS ARE IN
COLORADO SPRINGS, THERE'S TWO.
AND THEN ALL THE OTHER CLUBS
WOULD BE NOT A PART OF THAT
STATISTIC.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS WRONG WITH
THIS MAN.
I DON'T KNOW WHY HE NEEDED TO
ACT IN THIS WAY.
BUT HE OBVIOUSLY HAD SOME
FEELINGS TOWARDS -- I DON'T KNOW
IF IT WAS TRANSGENDER PEOPLE,
GAYS, LESBIANS, I DON'T KNOW.
CLUB Q IS A SAFE PLACE FOR
EVERYBODY.
EVERYBODY IN THE SPECTRUM OF THE
RAINBOW.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHO HE WAS
TARGETING BUT I FEEL IT WAS
SOMETHING AIMED DIRECTLY AT MY
COMMUNITY.
YET AGAIN, ANOTHER TIME IN OUR
COUNTRY.
>>> LET'S BRING IN SONY BURTS
FROM THE STATE'S LEADING A
ADVOCATOR FOR ADVANCING THE
RIGHTS OF LGBTQ PEOPLE AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU ALL.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT HOW CLUB Q
HOLDS SUCH SYMBOLISM.
WE HEARD THE GOVERNOR SAY OVER
THE WEEKEND THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE A SAFE SPACE IN THE
COMMUNITY, AND IT WAS ANYTHING
BUT.
ROSA JUST REPORTED THAT THE D.A.
IS LOOKING AT THIS,
INVESTIGATING THIS THROUGH THE
LENS OF A HATE CRIME.
THAT'S A STEP SHY OF SAYING IT
WAS A HATE CRIME DEFINITIVELY.
I WONDER IF THERE'S ANY QUESTION
IN YOUR MIND.
>> NO.
TO ME -- WE DEFINITELY DON'T
WANT TO MAKE ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
MOTIVE AND THINGS LIKE THAT AS
AN INVESTIGATION IS UNDER WAY
AND AS IT CONTINUES, BUT I THINK
AS SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN TO CLUB
Q AND GREW UP IN CLUB Q IN A LOT
OF WAYS, I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE
YOU COULD CALL IT AT THIS POINT.
>> SO IF THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
THE SAFE SPACE, IS THERE ANY
SAFE SPACE FOR MEMBERS OF THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY IN COLORADO
SPRINGS RIGHT NOW?
WHAT ARE THEY TELLING YOU?
>> I THINK RIGHT NOW WE ARE --
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN THE ARBITERS
OF OUR SAFE SPACES, RIGHT?
WE'RE ALWAYS RESPONSIBLE FOR
CREATING THEM.
UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE IN A LOT OF
WAYS BEEN THE ONLY FOLKS
INVESTED IN KEEPING THEM SAFE.
I THINK RIGHT NOW THERE AREN'T A
LOT OF SAFE SPACES IN REALITY I
THINK WHAT EVERYBODY IS FEELING
IS THIS IMMENSE AMOUNT OF GRIEF,
IMMENSE AMOUNT OF SORROW,
IMMENSE AMOUNT OF UNDESCRIBABLE
FEELINGS FOR AN UNIMAGINABLE
SITUATION THAT, UNFORTUNATELY
WITH THE LANDSCAPE OF WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IN THE PAST IS IMAGINABLE
IN A LOT OF WAYS.
RIGHT NOW I THINK IT'S KIND OF
UP TO US TO LEAN INTO EACH OTHER
AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN MAKE
THOSE SAFE SPACES, BUT ALSO HAVE
FOLKS OUTSIDE OF OUR COMMUNITY
INVESTED IN KEEPING THEM SAFE.
>> MICHAEL ANDERSON IS THE
BARTENDER THAT KAITLAN MENTIONED
MOMENTS AGO.
I WANT YOU TO HEAR IT AND
RESPOND TO IT.
>> HE'S ALWAYS BEEN A FRIEND TO
ME, BUT HE WAS MY SUPERVISOR AT
CLUB Q.
HE WAS THE BAR SUPERVISOR AND HE
WAS THE BEST SUB PERVISOR ANYON
COULD HAVE ASKED FOR.
HE MADE ME WANT TO COME INTO THE
WORK AND MADE ME JUST WANT TO BE
A PART OF THE POSITIVE CULTURE
WE WERE TRYING TO CREATE THERE.
AMAZING PERSON.
HE WAS A LIGHT IN MY LIFE, AND
IT'S STILL SURREAL THAT WE'RE
EVEN TALKING ABOUT HIM IN PAST
TENSE LIKE THIS.
>> HE'S TALKING ABOUT DANIEL
ASTON WHO WAS KILLED SATURDAY
NIGHT WHILE BARTENDING AT THE
CLUB AS WELL.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> IT'S -- IT'S DEFINITELY HARD
TO HEAR SOMEBODY THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE I HEARD UP UNTIL THIS
POINT I HEARD PEOPLE DESCRIBE AS
A BEACON OF LIGHT AND A
WONDERFUL PERSON TO WORK WITH.
TO HEAR SOMEBODY HAVE TO
DESCRIBE SOMEONE IN THE PAST
TENSE THAT THEY EITHER JUST SAW
OR JUST HAD AN INTERACTION WITH
IS HEARTBREAKING, AND THE
DESCRIPTION LEADS ME TO A PLACE
WHERE -- CLUB Q HAS BEEN THAT.
SO THAT PERSON REPRESENTED WHAT
CLUB Q WAS TO ALL OF US, AN OPEN
AND WELCOMING SPACE THAT MADE US
FEEL LIKE WE COULD BE OURSELVES,
ESPECIALLY IN SITUATIONS WHERE A
LOT OF PEOPLE CAN'T BE AUTHENTIC
AT HOME.
CLUB Q PROVIDED THAT SAFE SPACE
AND THE BAR TENDERS WERE A PART
OF THAT ECOSYSTEM.
>> STONEY, YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
NEED FOR PEOPLE OUTSIDE THE
COMMUNITY TO BE INVESTED IN IT.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THIS, AS
WE'RE LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION, WHAT DO YOU WANT
TO HEAR FROM YOUR POLITICAL
LEADERS, FROM YOUR ELECTED
LEADERS IN THE STATE WHEN
THEY'RE SPEAKING OUT ABOUT THIS?
>> I THINK FOR US IT'S POINTED.
I THINK OFTENTIMES WHEN THINGS
HAPPEN VERY VIGILS AND SPACE
MADE SO THAT FRIENDS AND FAMILY
CAN GRIEVE AND BEGIN THAT
PROCESS IN COMMUNITY, AND I
THINK TOO OFTEN THERE ARE --
WHETHER IT BE LOCAL OFFICIALS,
THINGS OF THAT NATURE THAT DO
COME AND THEY'RE THERE FOR THAT
FIRST WAVE OF GRIEF, BUT THAT
AFTER THAT THERE'S REALLY
NOTHING TANGIBLE THAT WE CAN
LOOK BACK TO AND SAY THIS IS
WHAT CAME OUT OF THAT.
I THINK WHAT WE NEED FROM OUR
LEADERS AT THIS POINT IS JUST BE
TRUE TO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IN
YOUR SPEECHES, IMPLEMENT THOSE
THINGS, AND WE ALSO NEED TO ALL
SIT AT THE TABLE AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE NEXT STEPS ARE, BECAUSE
AS TRAGIC AND HEARTBREAKING AS
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE, OUR
WORK REALLY BEGINS TODAY.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SPACE FOR
FRIENDS AND FAMILY TO GRIEVE AND
TO BE THERE FOR THEM AND PROVIDE
COMMUNITY, BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
HAVE ACTION BEHIND OUR WORDS AND
THAT FALLS ON OUR LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL OFFICIALS TO DO
THAT.